Today,
what I'd like to do is begin our survey of Genesis one through 11,
uh,
in order to illustrate the way that biblical writers and precisely who we think
they were and when they lived is something we'll talk about later.
But the way biblical writers drew upon the cultural and religious legacy of the
ancient Near East that we've been talking about,
um,
its stories and its imagery even as they transformed it,
uh,
in order to conform to a new vision of a non mythological God,
we're going to be looking at some of Caltrans ideas as we read some of these
texts.
Um,
now one of the scholars who's written quite extensively
okay
and eloquently on the adaptation of ancient near eastern motifs in Biblical
literature,
come on and you can family,
um,
is uh,
a scholar by the name of knock him Sarnai highly recommend,
uh,
his book and appears on your optional reading list.
And I'll be drawing very heavily on Sarnia's work as well as the work of some
other scholars who have spent a great deal of time comparing is relayed in
ancient near eastern stories,
particularly these opening chapters.
Um,
in order to see the features that they share and to wonder if perhaps there
isn't after all,
a chasm that divides them quite deeply in our consideration of genesis one and
two,
we first need to consider a Babylonian,
epic,
and epic that is known by its opening words at the top of the column over there.
They knew my alias,
which means when on high,
the opening words of this epic and the epic opens before the formation of heaven
and earth,
nothing existed except water and water existed.
In two forms.
There's the primeval fresh water,
fresh water ocean,
which is identified with a male divine principle,
a male God up.
So you have a prime evil saltwater ocean,
which is identified with a female divine principle.
Tmr TMR appears as this watery,
uh,
ocean,
but also as a very fierce dragon like monster.
Uh,
I will be reading sections from Spicer's translation of a pneuma alien,
part of the anthology put together by Pritchard.
It begins when on high,
they haven't had not been named from ground below,
had not been called by name,
not but primordial Appsu there.
Begetter and Moomoo Tiamat.
She who bore them all their water's commingling as a single body.
No Reed Hut had been matted,
had no marshland,
had appeared when no gods,
whatever had been brought into being uncalled by,
name their destinies undetermined.
Then it was that the gods were formed within them.
So there's some sort of commingling or union of this male and female divine,
these male and female divine principles,
a sexual union of opposite and TMF that begins a process of generation and it
produces first demons,
monsters.
Eventually God's will begin to emerge now in time Tiamat and ops who are
disturbed by the den and the tumult of these younger gods,
the divine brothers banded together.
They disturbed Tiamat as they surged back and forth.
Yeah,
they troubled the mood of Tiamat by their hilarity and the abode of heaven.
Absolute opening his mouth said unto resplendent Tiamat there ways are very
lazy.
Load some unto me by day I find no relief nor proposed by night.
I will destroy you.
I will wreck their ways.
That quiet may be restored.
Let us have rest.
Then answered.
Miu Miu Miu Miu Tiamat,
giving counsel to up Sue Ellen wishing and ungracious was mama's advice.
Do destroy my father.
The mutinous ways then shalt thou have relief by day and rest by night.
When absolute heard this,
his face grew radiant because of the evil he planned against the gods,
his sons.
So he decides to destroy the gods and he is thwarted by a water God named Ia and
earth.
Earth,
water gods,
sorry,
he's a combination earth water God named Ian and [inaudible] was killed.
Tiamat now is enraged and she's bent on revenge.
She makes plans to attack all of the gods with her assembled forces.
The gods are terrified and they need a leader to lead them against her army.
And they turn to Marduk.
Marduk agrees to lead them in battle against [inaudible] and her assembled
forces.
Uh,
her forces are under the,
I guess,
general ship of Kingo.
Uh,
and uh,
he agrees to lead them against Tiamat and Kangoo unconditioned that he be
granted sovereignty,
right.
And he sets terms
his heart exalting.
He said,
creator of the God's destiny of the great gods.
If indeed I as your avenger am to vanquish Tiamat and save your lives and set up
the assembly,
proclaim supreme my destiny.
Let my word instead of you determine the fates.
Unalterable Shelby,
what I may bring into being neither recalled nor changed shall be the command of
my lips.
And the agreement is struck and Marduk fells Tiamat in battle.
Uh,
it's a fierce battle and there is in fact a memorable passage that um,
details her demise in fury.
Tiamat cried out allied to the roots.
Her legs shook both together and then joined issue tms and Marta.
They strove in single combat Lockton battle.
The Lord Marduk spread out his net to enfold her the evil wind which followed
behind.
He let loose in her face when TMR opened her mouth to consume him,
he drove in the evil wind that she closed,
not her lips,
and that's the fierce winds charged her belly.
Her body was distended and her mouth was wide open.
He released the Arrow,
it tore her belly.
It cut through her inside,
splitting the heart,
having thus subdued her,
he extinguished her life.
He casts down her carcass to stand upon it.
Well,
what do you do with a carcass of a ferocious monster?
You build a world and that's what mark did.
He takes the carcass,
you slices it into two halves rather like a clam shell and out of the top half
he creates the ferment,
the heaven with the other half.
He creates the land,
the earth.
He split her like a shellfish into two parts.
Half of her he set up and sealed as a sky,
pulled down the bar and posted guards.
He bade them to allow not her waters to escape,
right?
So he has used her body to press back her waters and that's what the ceiling is.
The firmament,
a firm beaten the sheet or or or a structure that's holding back waters.
One little holes come along,
that's rain coming through and the bottom part is the land which is pressing
down waters below.
They come up every now and then in springs and rivers and seas and lakes and
things.
That is the creative word but world.
But he doesn't stop there and he creates various heavenly bodies at this point.
He constructed stations for the great gods.
The heavenly bodies are understood a stations for the great gods fixing their
astral likenesses as constellations.
He determined the year by designating the zones.
He set up three constellations for each of the 12 months.
The moon,
he caused to shine the night to him and trusting and then the complaints begin
to roll in.
The gods are very unhappy because they have now been assigned specific duties in
the maintenance of the cosmos.
You know the Moon,
God has to come up at night and hang around for a while and go back down and the
sun has to trundle across the sky and they're pretty unhappy about this and they
want relief from working and laboring at their assigned stations.
And so Marduk seeds to this demand,
he takes blood from the slain general Kingo,
the leader of tms army,
the rebels,
Andy fashion's a human being with the express purpose of freeing the gods from
menial labor.
Blood.
I will mass and caused bones to be,
I will establish,
establish a savage man shall be his name,
barely savage man.
I will create,
he shall be charged.
But the service of the gods that they might be at ease.
It was Kingo who can tribe the uprising and made Tiamat rebel and joined battle.
So they bound him,
holding him before Ia and out of king goes blood.
They fashioned mankind and IA impose the service and let free the gods.
So the grateful gods now recognize the sovereignty of Marduk and they build him
a magnificent shrine or temple in Babylon
pronounced about l,
which simply means gateway of the gods,
the gate of the god Babylon meets the city.
That is the gateway of the gods and a big banquet follows and mark mark is
praise for all that he's accomplished in his kingship is confirmed and a Pneuma,
a leash ends.
It was the great national epic of the city of the bell or Babylon.
It was recited during the New Year festival,
which was the most important festival on the cultic calendar and not come Sarna
points out that it had four main functions,
which I've listed over here.
The first of those functions is the organic.
It tells us a story of the birth of the gods,
where they came from.
It's second function is cosmological.
It's explaining cosmic phenomena,
the land,
the sky,
the,
the heavenly,
um,
uh,
bodies and so on and uh,
and their origins.
It also serves a social and political function because the portrait or picture
of the universe or the world and its structure corresponds to and legitimates
the structure of Babylonian society.
The position and the function of the humans in the scheme of creation
corresponds or parallels precisely the position of slaves and Mesopotamian
society.
The position and function of look at the top of the hierarchy of authority,
parallels and legitimates the Babylonian King and with others are,
you know,
arranged within this pyramid that falls below.
Um,
it also,
the epic also explains and mirrors the rise of Babela is one of the great cities
in the ancient Near East that explains its rise to power and mark ducks rise
from being a city God to being at the head of the Pantheon of,
of a large empire.
This also had a Celtic,
um,
function,
as a,
as well,
according to Sarna and some other scholars,
the conflict,
that battle scene between Tiamat and Marduk,
which is described at some length,
symbolizes the,
the conflict or the battle between the forces of chaos and the forces of,
of Cosmos or cosmic order.
And that's a perpetual conflict.
Um,
uh,
each year it's a dramatized by the cycle of the seasons.
And at a certain time of the year it seems that the forces of darkness and
chaos,
our prevailing,
but each spring,
once again,
cosmic order and life return.
So the epic served as a kind of script for the reenactment of the primeval
battle in a cultic or temple setting.
And that reenactment helped to ensure the victory of the forces of,
of Cosmos and life each year over the forces of chaos and death.
So if we recall now some of the things we were talking about last time in the
theories of Kauffman,
um,
we might describe the world view that's expressed by a pneuma elite in the
following way.
And this is certainly what Sarna does.
We're going to consider,
first of all,
the view of the gods,
the view of humans and the view of the world,
right?
Three distinct categories.
First of all,
the gods,
the gods are clearly limited,
right?
The God to make a plan and they're sorted by another God who then murders that,
that God,
um,
they are a moral,
some of them are,
are nicer and better than others,
but they're not necessarily morally good or or righteous.
They emerge from this indifferent,
primal realm,
these,
this w a mixture of salt and sea waters that is the source of all being in the
source of ultimate power,
but they age and they mature and they fight and they die.
They're not wholly good,
not wholly evil,
and no one's got one.
No one.
God's will is absolute.
The portrait of humans that emerges is that humans are unimportant meals.
They are the slaves of the gods.
The gods have little reciprocal interest in or concern for them and they create
human beings to do the work of running the world.
To some degree,
they look upon them as slaves or pawns the picture of the world.
That would seem to emerge from this story is that it is a morally neutral place.
That means that for humans it can be a difficult and hostile place.
The best bet perhaps is to serve the god of the day,
whatever God might be ascendant to earn his favor and perhaps his protection.
But even that God will have limited powers and abilities and may in fact be
defeated or may turn on his devotees.
Now if we turn to the creation story,
the first of the two creation stories that are in the Bible,
because in fact there are two creation stories with quite a few contradictions
between them.
But if we turn to the first creation story in genesis one it concludes in
genesis two verse four.
And not for nothing,
but everyone understands that the function of the colon,
right?
So if we say genesis one one,
I mean chapter one,
verse one and then it goes to genesis two,
chapter two verse four,
left side of the colon is chapter,
right side of the colon is verse.
And every sentence has a verse number in the Bible.
Okay,
approximately sentence.
Um,
if we look now,
we'll see a different picture emerging.
The biblical God in this story,
which I hope you have read,
um,
is presented as being supreme and unlimited.
That's connected with the lack of mythology in genesis one,
or rather the suppression of mythology.
Okay.
There's a distinction between the two and we'll have to talk about that and hope
that you'll get into some of that in section as well.
I'm using the term mythology now the way we used it in the last lecture when we
were talking about Calvin work,
the theology is used to describe a stories that deal with the birth,
the life events of,
of Gods and demigods,
sometimes legendary heroes,
but narrating a sequence of events.
The biblical creation account is non mythological because there is no biography
of God in here.
God simply is.
There's no theater agony,
no account of his birth.
Um,
there's no story out of,
through,
by means of which he emerges from some other realm in the Mesopotamian account.
The gods themselves are created and then not even created first.
Actually,
the first generation of beings creates these odd demons and monsters.
And God's only are created after several generations.
And the god of Creation Marduk is actually kind of a latecomer in the picture.
Um,
and this is also a good time for us to draw a distinction between mythology and
myth.
Um,
Calvin and others have claimed that mythology is not in certainly this biblical
story or if it's not there,
it's at least suppressed.
Um,
but in contrast,
myth is not mythology.
Myth is a term we use to refer to a traditional.
Um,
it's often fanciful.
It relates imaginatively events,
which it,
it claims happen in historical time,
not in a primordial realm before time.
And a myth is designed to explain some kind of practice or ritual or custom or
natural phenomenon.
And that is why to this day,
you know,
there,
I don't know,
give me some myths that we all know of,
you know,
of Paul Bunyan's acts or handle is some something in American nature,
which I now no longer remember.
But myths are fanciful,
imaginative tales that are trying to explain the existence of either a thing or
a practice or even a belief.
Sometimes it's a story that's,
um,
availed explanation of,
of a truth.
We think of parables perhaps or allegories.
Um,
and so the claim that's often made is that the Bible,
it doesn't have full blown mythology.
It's,
it doesn't focus on stories about the lives and deaths and interactions of,
of Gods,
but it does certainly contain myths.
It has traditional stories and legends,
some quite fanciful whose goal it is to explain how and why something is what it
is.
So we turned into genesis one,
we have an absence of Thiago Annie and mythology in the sense of a biography of
God in this opening chapter.
And that means the absence of a met a divine realm.
If you remember nothing else from this course,
and certainly for the midterm exam,
you should remember the words met a divine realm.
If there's a little hint for you there,
okay.
It's an important concept.
I don't have to buy into it.
You just have to know it.
Okay?
Um,
but there is an absence of what Calvin would call this Metta divine round,
this primordial realm from which the gods emerge.
We also therefore have no sense that God is imminent in nature or tied to
natural substances or for not or phenomena.
So the biblical God's powers and knowledge do not appear to be limited by the
prior existence of any other substance or power.
Nature also is not divine.
It's Demythologize d divinized if that's a word.
The created world is not divine.
It is not the physical manifestation of various deities and earth got a water
God and so on.
The line of demarcation there for between the divine and the natural and human
worlds would appear to be clear.
So to summarize in genesis one,
um,
the view of God is that there is one supreme God who is Creator and sovereign of
the world who simply exists,
who appears to be in corporeal and who,
um,
and for whom the,
the realm of nature is,
um,
is separate and subservient.
Um,
he has no life story,
know mythology and his will is absolute indeed.
Creation takes place through the simple expression of his will.
When God began to create heaven and earth.
And then there's a parent's thetical clause,
God said,
let there be light.
And there was light.
He willed,
expressed his will that there'd be light and there was light.
And that's very different from um,
many ancient near eastern cause magnesium,
which there's always a sexual pre a principle at work in creation.
Creation is always result of procreation in some way.
Male and female principals combining,
um,
there's a very similar Egyptian creation story actually in which the god Pathak
just wills let this be less very reads very much like genesis one.
And yet even so there's still a sexual act that follows the expression of those
wills.
Um,
so it,
it is still different.
Consider now the portrait of humans,
humankind that emerges from the biblical creation story in contrast to
[inaudible] a leash in genesis,
humans are important.
Genesis one,
humans are important and in fact,
the biblical view of,
of humans really emerges from both of the creation stories if they're,
when they're read together.
The story here in genesis one and then the creation story that occupies much of
of two and three.
The two accounts are extremely different,
but they both signaled the unique position and dignity of the human being.
And the first account in genesis one the creation of the human is clearly the
climactic divine act.
Um,
after this God can rest and a sign of the humans.
Importance is the fact that humans are said to be created in the image of God.
Right?
This occurs in Genesis one verse 26 let us make man in our image after our
likeness.
What might that mean?
Looking at the continuation of the verse of the passage,
we have some idea because humans we see are going to be charged with specific
duties towards and rights over the created world and it seems therefore that the
idea of being created in the image of God is connected with those special rights
and duties.
A creature is required who was distinguished in certain ways from other animals.
How are humans distinguished from other animals?
You could make a long list but it might include things like the capacity for
language and higher thought or abstract thought conscience.
I'm self control free will.
So if those are the distinctive characteristics that earn the human being
certain rights over creation,
but also give them duties towards creation and the human is distinct from
animals and being created in the image of God.
Now there's perhaps a connection to be godlike is to perhaps possess some of
these characteristics and being created in the image of God carries a further
implication and implies that human life is somehow sacred and deserving of
special care and protection.
And that's why in genesis nine verse six we read whoever sheds the blood of man
in exchange for that man shall his blood be shed for in the image of God was man
created.
Invoke that rationale from Genesis one in the absolute prohibition on on murder.
There is no way to compensate or punish someone for murder.
It's simply means forfeiture of one's own life.
That's how secret human life is.
That's the biblical view.
So the concept of the divine image in humans,
uh,
right,
that's a,
that's a powerful idea that there is a divine image in humans and that breaks
with other ancient conceptions of the human.
In genesis one humans are not the meals of God and in fact,
genesis expresses the antithesis of this.
We're in a new [inaudible] service was imposed upon the God on the human,
so the gods were free.
You don't have to worry about anything that humans would take care of gods in.
We have the reverse.
It's almost like a polemic Olin version and genesis one the very first
communication of God to the human that's created is concerned for that
creature's physical needs and welfare.
He says in Genesis One verses 28 and 29 he blesses them.
God blessed them and God said to them,
be fertile and increase.
Fill the earth and master it.
Rule the fish of the sea,
the birds of the sky and all the living things that creep on earth.
In Genesis two verse 16 after the creation story there and the Lord God
commanded the man saying of every tree of the garden,
you are free to eat.
His first thought is,
what are you going to eat?
I want you to be fruitful and multiply and so on.
So humans and genesis are not presented as the helpless victims of blind forces
of nature.
They're not the meals and servants of capricious gods.
They are creatures of majesty and dignity,
and they are of importance to objects of concern for the God who has created
them.
At the same time.
And I think very much in line with the assertion that humans are created in the
image of God.
Humans are not in fact gods.
They are still creatures in the sense of created things and they are dependent
on a higher power.
So in the second creation story beginning in Genesis two,
four,
we read that the first human is formed when God fashions it from the dust of the
earth or clay.
Um,
there are lots of ancient near eastern stories of gods fashioning humans from
clay.
We have depictions of gods as potters at a potter's wheel just turning out lots
of little humans.
Um,
but the biblical account,
as much as it borrows from that Motif,
again,
takes pains to distinguish that and elevate the human first.
The fashioning of the human from clay is again,
in that story.
It's the climactic or uh,
well,
not quite climactic.
Um,
it's the penultimate I suppose moment in the story.
The final climactic act of creation is the creation of the female from the male
that is actually the peak of creation.
What can I say?
Second is significantly not an afterthought.
It's the peak of creation a second and significantly.
God himself blows the breath of life into Adam's nostrils.
So while he fashions this clay figure,
all right,
this,
this carcass actually and then reads life his own life into it.
So in the second creation story,
just as in the first,
there's a sacred imprint of some kind that distinguishes the human creation from
the other creatures.
So this idea that the human being is a mixture of,
um,
uh,
of clay.
He's molded from clay,
but enlivened by the breath I've got.
Um,
it captures that paradoxical mix of sort of earthly and divine elements,
dependence and freedom that marks the human as unique.
It should further be noted that in the creation first creation account,
there's no implication that man and woman are in any kind of unequal
relationship before God.
The Hebrew word that designates the creature created by God is the word a dumb.
It's actually not a proper name,
small lay.
It is a dumb,
it's a generic term.
It's simply means human or more precisely earthling because it comes from the
word [inaudible],
which means the ground or earth.
So this is an a dumb and earthling,
a thing that has been taken from the earth.
Genesis one states that God created the,
a dumb with a definite article.
This is not a proper name.
God created the a dumb,
the earthling male and female created he them.
That's a line,
that's vex commentators for centuries,
um,
and has spawned many very fascinating interpretations and you will be reading
some of those in the readings that are assigned for section discussion next
week.
Um,
and I think having a great deal of fun with them more over this,
this earthling seems that seems to include both male and female is then said to
be in the,
in the image of God.
So that suggests that the ancient Israelites didn't conceive of God is gendered
or necessarily gendered.
The dom,
the earthling male and female was made in the image of God.
Even in the second creation account.
It's not clear that the woman is subordinate to the man.
Um,
many medieval Jewish commentators enjoy pointing out that she was not made from
his head so that she not rule over him,
but she wasn't made from his foot so that she would be subservient to him.
She was made from his side so that she would be a companion to him.
Um,
and the creation of women,
as I said,
is in fact the climactic creative act.
And the second genesis account with her formation creation is now complete.
So the biblical creation stories individually and jointly present a portrait of
the human as the pinnacle and purpose of creation,
godlike in some way in possession of distinctive faculties and characteristics,
um,
that equipped them for stewardship over the world that God has created.
Finally,
let's talk about the image of the world that emerges from the creation story.
In Genesis one,
in these stories,
there is a very strong emphasis on the essential goodness of the world.
We call some of Calvin's ideas or categories.
Again,
one of the things he claims is that in a polytheistic system,
which is morally neutral,
where you have some primordial realm that spawns demons,
monsters,
gods evil is a permanent necessity.
It's just built into the structure of the cosmos.
Um,
because of the fact that all kinds of divine beings,
good and bad,
are generated and locked in conflict.
So the world isn't essentially good in its nature or essentially bad.
Note the difference in Genesis after each act of creation,
what does God say it is?
Good,
right?
Genesis one verse four,
verse 10,
verse 12,
Verse 18,
Verse 21,
verse 25 and after the creation of living things,
the text states that God found all that he made to be very good.
So there are seven occurrences of the word good in genesis.
That's something you want to watch for.
If you're reading a passage of the Bible and you're noticing a word coming up a
lot,
count them.
This is probably going to be seven or 10.
They loved doing that.
Um,
the seven fold or the tenfold repetition of a word,
such a word,
is called a light works
recurring word that is,
becomes thematic.
That's a favorite literary technique of the biblical author.
So we read genesis one and we hear this recurring and it was good and he looked
and it was good and he looked at it was good.
And we have this tremendous rush of optimism.
The world is good.
Humans are important.
They have purpose and dignity.
The biblical writers rejecting the concept of a primordial evil,
a concept found in the literature of the ancient Near East.
So for the biblical writer of this story,
it would seem that evil is not a metaphysical reality built into the structure
of the universe.
So all signs of a cosmic battle or some primordial act of violence between the
forces of chaos and evil and the forces of Cosmos and good are eliminated in a
new,
my alias cosmic order is achieved only after a violent struggle with very
hostile forces.
But in genesis,
creation is not the result of a struggle between divine antagonists.
God imposes order on the d mythologized elements that he finds water,
but it's just water.
Okay,
let's look a little bit more closely at genesis one to make this case.
The chapter begins with a temporal clause,
which is unfortunately often translated in the beginning,
which implies that what follows is going to give you an ultimate account of the
origins of the universe.
You sort of expect something like in the beginning,
God created the heaven and earth like this was the first thing to happen in
time,
right?
So that translation causes people to believe that the story is giving me an
account of the first event in time forward.
But it's actually a bad translation.
The Hebrew phrase that starts the book of Genesis is pretty much exactly like
the phrase,
it starts a new Ma,
a leash.
When on high,
um,
there was a whole bunch of water and stuff.
Then suddenly this happened very similar in the Hebrew.
It's better translated this way.
When God began creating the heavens and the earth,
he said,
let there be light and there was light.
And that translation suggests that the story isn't concerned to depict the
ultimate origins of the universe.
It's interested in explaining how am I the world?
Got The way it is.
When God began this process of creating the heaven and the earth,
and the earth was unformed and void,
and w you know,
his wind was on the surface of the deep and so on.
He said,
let there be light and there was light.
So we find that effect.
Something exists.
It has no shape.
So creation in genesis one is not described as a process of making something out
of nothing.
That's a notion referred to as creation.
Ex Niccolo low creation of something out of utter nothing.
Um,
it's instead a process of organizing preexisting materials and imposing order on
those chaotic materials.
So we begin with this chaotic mass.
Um,
and then there's the Ruach of God.
Now,
sometimes this word Ruach is kind of anachronistically translated as spirit
really doesn't mean that in the Hebrew Bible and later levels of Hebrew,
it will start to mean that,
but it is really wind.
Ra is wind.
So when God began to create heaven on earth,
the earth being unformed and void,
the wind of God weeping over the deep.
Remember the cosmic battle between Marduk and Tiamat Marduk,
the storm God who released his wind against Tiamat,
the primeval,
primeval deep,
the primeval water.
I'm representing the forces of chaos and you should immediately hear the great
similarities.
Our story opens with a temporal clause.
When on high when God began creating,
we have a wind that sweeps over chaotic waters just like the wind of Marduk
released into the face of tms.
And the Hebrew term is particularly fascinating.
In fact,
the text says,
and there is darkness on the face of deep,
no definite article.
The word deep is a proper name,
perhaps Hebrew word is to home means deep and etymologically.
It's exactly the same word as t on that.
The attending is just feminine.
So TM to home,
it's the same word,
it's a related word.
So the wind over the face of deep.
Now this d mythologize.
So it's as if they're in evoking the story that would have been familiar and yet
changing it.
So the storyteller has actually set the stage for retelling the cosmic battle
story that everyone knew.
That was a story that surely was near and dear to the hearts of many ancient
Israelites and ancient near eastern listeners.
So all the elements are there for the retelling of that story.
We've got wind,
we've got a primeval,
chaotic,
watery mass or deep and then surprise,
there's no battle.
There's just a word.
Let there be light.
And the ancient near eastern listener would prick up their ears.
And where's the battle?
Where's the violence?
Where's the Gore?
I thought I knew this story.
So something new,
something different was being communicated in this story.
And don't think the biblical writers didn't know this Motif of creation
following upon a huge cosmic battle,
particularly a battle with a watery dragon like monster.
There are many poetic passages in poetic sections of the Bible that contained
very clear and explicit illusions to that myth.
It was certainly known and told Israelite children.
Um,
and part of the culture we haven't mentioned in Joe,
we haven't mentioned in the following psalm,
psalm 74 versus 12 to 17.
Oh God,
my king from of old who brings deliverance throughout the land.
It was you who drove back the sea with your might,
who smashed the heads of the monsters in the waters.
It was you who crushed the heads of Leviathan.
A sea monster.
Um,
other psalms also contains similar lines.
Isaiah 51 verses nine through 10.
It was you that hacked Rayhab.
This is another name of a primeval water monster in pieces.
It was you that pierce the drag and it was you that dried up the sea,
the waters of the great deep.
These were familiar stories.
They were known in Israel.
They were recounted in Israel.
They were stories of a god who violently slays the forces of chaos represented
as watery dragons as a prelude to creation.
And the rejection of this motif for this idea in genesis one,
um,
is pointed and purposeful.
It's deemed pathologization removal of the creation account from the realm.
And the world of mythology is pointed and purposeful.
It wants us to,
to conceive of God as an uncontested God who,
through the power of his word,
or we'll create the cosmos.
And he follows that initial ordering by setting up celestial bodies just as
Martin did.
They're not in themselves.
However,
divinities they are merely God's creations.
In the biblical text,
the firmament appears to be um,
uh,
beaten.
Uh,
the,
the word in Hebrew is something that's been beaten out like a metal worker would
a hammer out a thin sheet of metal.
And that's what the from Minot,
this by the way is the portrait of the world.
Looks a lot like my map of the ancient near east,
but it's not.
So you have this firmament which is beaten back to hold back primeval waters
that are pressing in.
You have land which is holding down the water's here.
We inhabit the bubble that's created in that way.
That's the image in a new my alias.
And it's the image of genesis one.
And later on when God gets mad,
he's going to open up some windows up here,
right?
And it's all going to the flood.
That's what's going to happen in the flood.
But that's the image of the world that you're working with.
So the firmament is sort of like an inverted bowl and beaten out sheet of metal.
That's an inverted bowl.
And again,
as I said,
echoes of a Ma alias where you have martik dividing the carcass of Tiamat like a
shellfish.
He separates the waters above and the waters below and creates this,
this space that will become the inhabited world.
Okay?
Now the story of creation in genesis one takes place over seven days and there's
a certain logic and parallelism to the six days of creating.
And I've written those parallels here.
Um,
there's a parallel between day one,
day four,
they two and five,
they three and six on Day One,
light and dark are separated.
On Day four,
the heavenly bodies that give off light by day or night or created.
On Day two,
the firmament is established,
that water is separated,
that bubble is opened up.
So we've got sky created and we've got the water's collected in certain areas
down here,
right water down here,
and we've got sky on day five,
the inhabitants of the skies and the waters are created birds and fish.
On Day three,
land is formed to make dry spots from the waters below.
So you have land being formed in day three it's separated out from the sea and
on day six you have the creation of land animals,
but days three and six each have an extra element.
And the fact that the first elements here pair up nicely with each other.
Suggest that the extra element on day three and the extra element on day six
might also be paired in some important way.
On Day three,
vegetation is produced,
is created and on day six humans are created after the creation of the land
animals.
So the implication is that the vegetation is for the humans and indeed it's
expressly stated by God that humans are to be given every fruit bearing tree and
seed bearing plant fruits and grains for food.
That's in genesis one 29.
That's what you are going to eat.
There's no mention of of um,
chicken or beef.
It's no mention made of animals for food.
In Genesis one verse 30,
God says that the animals are being given the green plants,
the grass and herbs for food.
In other words,
there should be no competition for food.
Humans have fruit and grain bearing vegetation.
Animals have the erbium [inaudible] and the grasses.
There is no excuse to live in anything but a peaceful coexistence.
Therefore,
humans,
according to genesis one,
were created vegetarian.
And in every respect,
the original creation is imagined as free of bloodshed and violence of every
kind.
And God saw that it was very good.
So on the seventh day,
God rested from his labors.
And for this reason he blessed the seventh day and declared it holy.
This is a word we'll be coming back to in about five or six lectures talking
about what it is to be holy.
But right now it essentially means that belongs to God.
Something's holy.
It doesn't belong to you,
it belongs to God.
Okay?
And part of the purpose of this story is to explain the origin of the observance
of the Sabbath.
The Sabbath.
The seventh day is a holy day.
So this is a myth in that sense that it's explaining some customer ritual among
the people.
So Israelite accounts of creation contained clear illusions to and resonances of
ancient near eastern cause manganese.
But perhaps Dan assist one can best be described as d mythologizing what was a
common cultural heritage?
There's a clear tendency in this story towards monotheism and the abstract terms
at Calvin described,
um,
uh,
transformation of widely known stories to express a monotheistic worldview was
clearly important to these particular biblical writers.
And we'll be talking later about who these writers were,
who wrote Genesis one as opposed to genesis two and three.
But these stories rival and implicitly polemicizing against the myths or
mythologies of Israel's neighbors.
They reject certain elements,
but they almost reject them by incorporating them,
right?
They incorporate and modify them.
So one of the things I've tried to claim in describing genesis one is that in
this story,
evil is represented not as a physical reality.
It's not built into the structure of the world,
right?
When God rests,
he's looking at the whole thing.
It's very good.
It's set up very well.
And yet we know that evil is a condition of human existence.
It's a,
it's a reality of life.
So how do we account for it?
And the Garden of Eden Story I think seeks to answer that question.
They actually,
there's a whole bunch of things,
but one thing it does,
I think is,
is try to answer that question and to assert that evil stems from human
behavior.
God created a good world,
but humans in the exercise of their moral autonomy,
they have the power to corrupt the good.
So the garden of Eden story communicates with Kauffman would identify as a basic
idea of a monotheistic worldview.
That evil isn't a metaphysical reality,
it's a moral reality.
What that means ultimately is that evil lacks inevitability depending on your
theory of human nature,
I suppose,
but it awesome it in.
It also means that that evil lies within the realm of human responsibility and
control.
Now,
not whom Sarna the scholar whose work I referred to earlier,
he points out that there's a very important distinction between the garden of
Eden Story and it's ancient near eastern parallels.
He says,
the Motif of a tree of life or a plant of life or a plant of eternal youth.
That's a motif that we do find in other ancient,
near eastern literatures in,
in ancient near eastern myth and ritual and iconography and the quest for such a
plant or the quest for immortality,
um,
that the plant promises that these were primary themes in,
in the Mesopotamian epic of Gilgamesh
will have occasion to talk in great depth about this story next time.
But by contrast,
Sarna says,
we haven't as yet uncovered a parallel in ancient near eastern literature to the
biblical tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
It's not the tree of knowledge.
It's a tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
So the longer phrase,
what is the significance of the fact that the Bible mentions both of these
trees?
It mentions a tree of life and the tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
and then goes on to just focus on the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
It virtually ignores the tree of life until we get to the end of the story.
And that's important.
But this tree of life,
which seems to be central to many other myths of this time and uh,
this of the world.
Sarna argues that the subordinate role of the tree of life signals the biblical
writers dissociation from a preoccupation with immortality.
The Biblical writer insists that the central concern of life is not mortality,
but morality and the drama of human life should revolve not around the search
for eternal life,
but around the moral conflict intention between a good God's designed for
creation and the freewill of human beings that can corrupt that good design.
The serpent tells eve that if she eats the fruit of the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil,
she will become like God.
And he's really not telling a lie in a certain respect and God knows that the
human beings will become like gods knowing good and evil.
It's one of the things about,
uh,
about God knows good and evil and has chosen the good,
right,
the Israelite,
the biblical writers,
sorts of this God that he is absolutely good.
The humans will become like gods,
knowing good and evil,
not because of some magical property in this fruit.
And it's not an apple by the way.
That's based on an interesting Mrs Translation.
Did we know what the fruit is?
Nobody.
I don't think we really know,
but it's definitely not an apple that's comes from the Latin word,
which sounds like apple.
The word Muslim for evil is close to the Latin word for apple,
which if anybody knows whatever.
And uh,
and so for the history,
you know,
our iconography began to represent this trees and apple tree and so on.
But it's not an apple tree.
I don't know if they had apple trees back then there.
Um,
but it's not because of some magical property in the fruit itself.
but because of the action of disobedience itself,
by choosing to eat of the fruit in defiance of God,
right?
This is the one thing God says,
you know,
don't do this.
You can have everything else in this garden.
Presumably even you can eat of the tree of life,
right?
It doesn't say you can't eat of that.
Who's to say they couldn't eat event and just live forever.
Don't eat of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
God says you can't eat of this tree when he's given all of that.
There has been about how many thousands of years of speculation on what's going
on and you're going to be reading a wonderful and interesting gnostic
interpretation.
So yeah,
there have been,
there's been lots of interesting and this is all in the realm of literary
interpretation.
Read the story closely.
See if you can figure out what's going on here.
Why does God do this?
Why isn't this in a way putting an obstacle in front of someone almost ensuring
they're going to trip over it.
Um,
that's been an argument that some commentators have made others see it
differently.
Um,
so keep that thought.
Take it to section and read.
Um,
Elaine Pagels work and some of the other interpretations.
That's something people have struggled with for centuries,
right?
Where does this come from?
Who is the serpent?
What's he doing there?
They're all very important.
It is true.
And maybe this will go a little bit of the distance towards answering it.
Um,
it's by eating of the fruit in defiance of God.
Human beings learned that they were able to do that,
that they are free moral agents.
They find that out.
They're able to choose their actions in conformity with God's will or in
defiance of God's will.
So paradoxically they learn that they have more autonomy.
Remember they were made in the image of God and they learned that they have
moral autonomy by making the defiant choice,
right?
The choice for disobedience.
The argument could be made that until they wants disobeyed,
how would they ever know that?
And then you raise all sorts of questions about,
well,
was this part of God's plan that they ought to know this and should know this so
that their choice for good actually becomes meaningful?
Is it meaningful to choose to do the good when you have no choice to do
otherwise or aren't aware that you have a choice to do otherwise?
So it was a wonderful 13th century commentator that says that God needed
creatures who could choose to obey him.
And therefore it was important for,
for Adam and Eve to do what they did and to learn that they have the choice not
to obey God so that their choice for God would become endowed with meaning.
That's one line of interpretation.
That's a gone through many theological systems for hundreds of years.
So the very action that brought them a god like awareness of their moral
autonomy was an action that was taken in opposition to God.
So we see them that having knowledge of good and evil is no guarantee that one
we'll choose or inclined towards the good.
That's what the serpent omitted in his speech,
right?
He said,
if you eat of that fruit,
of that tree of the knowledge of good and evil,
you'll become like God.
It's true in one sense,
but it's false.
In another,
he sort of admitted to point out,
he implies that it's the power of moral choice alone that is God like,
but the biblical writer will claim and uh,
many places that true godliness isn't simply power the power to do what one
wishes.
True Godliness means imitation of God.
The exercise of one's power.
In a manner that is God,
like good life affirming and so on.
So it's the biblical writers contention that the God of Israel is not only all
powerful,
but is essentially and necessarily good.
Those two elements cannot become disjoined.
They must always be conjoined in the biblical writers view.
And finally,
your humans will learn that the concomitant of their freedom is responsibility.
Their first act of defiance is punished harshly.
So they learn in this story that the moral choices and actions of humans have
consequences that have to be borne by the perpetrator.
So just to sum up,
Sarna sees in the garden of Eden story as I've just explained it,
a message that's in line with Calvin's thesis about the monotheistic worldview.
He says,
the story conveys the idea that quote evil is a product of human behavior,
not a principal inherent in the cosmos.
Man's disobedience is the cause of the human predicament.
Human freedom can be at one in the same time,
an omen of disaster and a challenge and opportunity.
We've looked at genesis two and three,
a little bit as an attempt to account for the problematic and paradoxical
existence of evil and suffering in a world created by a good God.
And that's a problem.
Monotheism really never completely conquers.
Um,
but other perspectives on this story or possible,
and when we come back on Monday,
we're going to look at it from an entirely different point of view and compare
it with the epic of Gilgamesh.